[Applause]
Wow Ripley's ship has been out in space
for 57 years but it looks like she's
aged 7 years well nobody said hypersleep
was perfect these guys any indication
that the air in here is breathable
certainly nothing since they walked in
here and if so why wear the masks at all
Kevin yeah listen I'm glad the cat ends
up being okay having said that shouldn't
the hypersleep settings be completely
different for different species did the
cat not age either how long was I out
there has no one discussed this with you
yet dreams position you had drifted
right through the core systems and it's
really just blind luck that a deep
Salvage team found you when they did how
did she drift through the core systems
without anyone knowing
in the previous movie Ripley thought
she'd be picked up within six weeks or
so but she then scooted through those
core systems like Sue Storm it's one in
a thousand really actually it's a ton
more than one in a thousand the odds are
astronomical that Ripley ship was found
space is like really really big I mean
you may think it's a long way to the
chemist but that's just peanuts to space
listen and so on movie takes the awesome
scene from the first one and turns it
into a silly gotcha dream sequence but I
guess all that exposition about her
being asleep for 57 years and stand-up
comedian Paul Reiser being in this movie
still holds despite the last part being
a dream sneaky you get to have a scary
moment pretend to kill your main star
and give the audience useful information
where did the company get file photos
like this wouldn't you have something
more official than what looks like
stills from the first movie I don't
understand this you've been here for
three and a half hours how many
different ways do you want me to tell
the same story this is likely what the
writers of the next fourteen
transformers movie said to Michael Bay
when they were locked in the Bastille
under his mansion why don't you just
check out lv-426 because I don't have to
there have been people there for over 20
years and they never complained about
any hostile organism and I neglected to
tell you this extremely important detail
until you confronted me after the
meeting
well future business cards are
ridiculously inefficient why is it
easier to give people a plastic card
that contacts you directly that a paper
card that has your number you're going
out there to destroy them right Ripley
who has first-hand knowledge of the ways
of the Whelan corporation trust someone
from the Whelan corporation when he says
they're not going out there to bring the
alien back also I don't quite understand
the motivations of the company here sure
we need a reason for Ripley to be in
this movie
but if they're taking her along then it
means they now believe her story about
the alien witch
she already gave them all the
information they need so why bring her
along you're staying here
who's gonna take care of him you see the
wheelchair dog owner from secret life of
pets wait why is Bishop on the manifest
Android shouldn't need hypersleep right
really makes you wonder why none of
these guys have an epic case of morning
wood but you only do fetches slippers
for you is that supposed to mean
yeah who's know what she's supposed to
be some kind of consultant I guess when
you're all in your undies waiting to go
to hypersleep nobody asks questions
about the new crew member it's the first
rule of orgies and space missions to
kill aliens Vasquez
have you ever been mistaken for a man oh
how about my speaking for being wait
that's jeanette goldstein right well I
guess we can forgive aliens for not
putting an actual Hispanic actor in this
role since there were none available in
right Maria Conchita Alonso yeah but
Bishop missed he'd be missed
sure he may not have expected Hudson's
hand to be under his butt the whole
point of this knife razzmatazz is that
he can go super fast and not miss bishop
maybe a great upgrade in Android
technology but he sucks at parlor tricks
we always have a synthetic gun I prefer
the term artificial person myself and
ridicule correctness also does it matter
what Bishop prefers how far as AI
progressed into sin C&C and if it's at
the point where androids have
preferences would they still be taking
orders from humans I think not
I'm shocked was it an older model and a
hyper die systems 128 to hyper dine is
that the offshoot of Cyberdyne are we
mixing our terminator alien franchises
is this after Skynet was officially
defeated or is this a parallel universe
god damned Terminator is always covering
up their goddamn tracks well that
explains it in the u2's Ovie's were a
bit twitchy
yeah but ash was specifically ordered to
get the specimen back to the base so
there was nothing wrong with its
behavior or programming there was
something wrong with the asshole who
told it to force a fucking magazine down
Ripley's throat I'm sorry we didn't have
time to brief you people before we left
gateway by they didn't have time to
brief the Marines before they left but
they have plenty of time between Gateway
and now why not shorten the hypersleep
cycle by at least an hour on the front
end and brief them then it's not like it
would dissuade anyone from the mission
they're already on board I only
to know one thing where they this is the
James Cameron ization of the Alien
franchise to bring in a bunch of grunts
and action this movie up but the
ulterior motive of the mission is to
bring some back so why they hired the
killing ass bunch of motherfuckers they
could find she thought they said illegal
aliens signed up that's racist although
it is kind of funny that this is a true
story that made it into the script
because Jeanette Goldstein actually
thought the movie was going to be about
illegal aliens when she auditioned I'm
not quite sure how that translates into
her playing a different race but hey a
jokes a joke EO how do I get out of this
chicken outfit the producers of this
movie took one look at weird science and
said hey Bill for this movie don't
change a thing a salsa now boss I'm
taking ass in off of these mech suits
man these things are a million times
better looking than what we see in the
third Matrix movie and that was 17 years
later where you want it Bay 12 please
these dudes seem incredibly impressed
that Ripley can manipulate the mech
loader bug this is well into the future
isn't this like being able to operate a
modern-day forklift well I know what
combats eating you know your places
combat seating is that a thing does that
mean there's a totally different
non-combat seating or a casual Friday
seating I wasn't aware of every time I
watched this movie I'm perplexed as to
why these heavily armed marines let
these two unarmed civilians tag along
okay Ripley has experience at a
paramilitary background perk that little
chicken is an executive that's like
taking Elon Musk to the center of a
firefight oh there's no doubt during the
soldiers grab their weapons and board
the spaceship scene that they had to
stop filming for several days due to
James Cameron's tech donors which are
known to last hours and even years damn
cookin they clean the windshield off a
little for United Airlines Drake check
your camera there seems to be a
malfunction
hitting or punching the thing makes the
thing more cliche I'm sure the colonist
built a bar out of necessity here but
where the fuck did they get the neon and
is that even necessary there are only 60
families here max but they probably all
know where the alcohol is served
alright thanks there was no need for you
to do that before now because as we all
know aliens don't attack when you first
walk into a building alien that looks
like a vagina is automatically more sex
education than any tendency high school
is willing to teach everyone else's
armor mounted light is pointing forward
but Drake's is pointing right at his
chin so that any enemy will have a great
view of its target for then why is
everyone at Banting toward it Newt a
smart little girl who survived the alien
attack decides to be a jump-scare dick
in front of these trigger-happy faces
wait Rebecca Newt was born in Hadleys
Hope and grew up here this is a
terraforming and mining base with very
few children but they not only had a
functional elementary school they had
time to give out awards for citizenship
also the crew was put into hypersleep to
fly out to this colony planet how much
time is actually passed
if second grade represents the good old
days for nu then this must be a period
of light months tops so shouldn't she be
way older if the trip was so long as to
require hypersleep come on we're wasting
that time yeah there's no reason to
continue to try to get information from
what looks like the sole survivor of a
xenomorph attack right Personal Data
transmitters every colonist had one
surgically implanted there within 20
klicks we'll read it out here once again
something that would be useful to do
immediately after they landed nude
there's no doubt that Newt knows of the
fantastic beasts and where to find them
[Music]
you know for someone who's lost their
entire friends and family and has eaten
nothing but beets for months it's a real
bitch Jesus Paul Rizer stealing Hispanic
acting jobs too sir I just do it
sergeant it would literally take less
than 30 seconds for Gorman to tell them
why they couldn't shoot the creatures
but hey who needs open communication
when you can use flamethrowers this is
exactly why you tell your soldiers why
they can't fire down here this one too
asshole they decided to check just
happened to have an alien ready to burst
out of her chest
they passed like 20 other people on the
way here right also how long have these
assholes been down here everything else
is long gone but this one colonist was
alive until exactly this point maybe
she's a late bloomer
seriously if no one was gonna listen to
Ripley then what was the point of her
being here I guess all that stuff about
the thermonuclear reactor blowing up and
there
was just a bunch of bullshit because
there was no way they didn't hit
something vital during this scene
apparently metal tires make the same
sound on an alien planet as rubber tires
on earth bastard aliens somehow slipped
by everyone then stowed away on the
mostly abandoned ship and motion sensors
didn't detect it for some reason all the
aliens were down in the high but even if
there was another one lurking around the
motion sensors didn't detect it and the
pilot didn't either expire well where
the fuck the most significant moment in
xenomorph evolution was when they
learned to quietly open cockpit doors
you see even the grunts in fucking
aliens didn't attend the Prometheus
school of running away from things but
it's pitch black right now so they're
pretty much screwed either way
how long after were declared overdue can
we expect a rescue 17 days from where
the same base Ripley and the crew left
if so why the hell did they go and a
hypersleep for 17 days it's just a
little longer than a regular moon
mission from the 20th century also if
the crew had left at least one person up
in the orbiter as common sense suggests
they'd be rescued in five minutes or
less and we'd have 70% less danger in
this movie first off they just sealed
off the doors to be barricaded in a
small place so why wait until now to
give this to Ripley say not everyone
should be wearing these locators at all
times right especially the non-military
Ripley and Burke who would be more apt
to get lost
geez for a compound that was recently
overtaken by an alien race this base has
some clean ass linen yeah nothing bad in
there because she's just a piece of
plastic new would be amazing at
cinemasins do you see that camera right
up there I can see you right through
that camera all the time you see if you
say I'll be looking at it at all times
and if I see one hint of an alien I'm
fast enough to run in here and kill it
before it gets to you
I want these specimens destroyed mr.
Burke gave instructions that they
wouldn't be kept alive in stasis for
return to the company labs Rick gave
Bishop the keep the specimens alive
order but he neglected to also give him
the don't tell everyone when I'm doing
because that'll freak everyone out they
may want to kill me order our one of
Newt watch went by without Ripley
looking at a security screen once you
take care of it won't you
it comes dad I'll do his bug Hicks finds
an extremely inopportune time to propose
a weird sex act to Ripley or is it hold
tight here whoa maybe this weapons
training scene is a sex scene Louie will
try to make us believe that Burke
somehow tossed a couple of facehuggers
into this room in order to
preg Nate Ripley and Newton but how did
he do that did he find some unconscious
facehuggers that he knew would wake up
eventually and slip them in there when
no one was looking this room is
soundproof for some reason you know
Burke I don't know which species is
worse you don't see them each other over
for a goddamn percentage yeah but how do
you know that have you Dian Fossey these
aliens before I'd love to see the movie
aliens in the mist
since when do these trackers actually
read the soldiers and the last scene
these were used we saw only the aliens
causing these sensors to be very
conveniently I might add even though
that's twice the movie has suggested the
sensors can pick up the humans 7:6
Ripley did you not see the last movie
there's so much no Pierre I'm shocked
Hicks didn't die of stupidity also I'm
kind of amazed that Ripley and the
others didn't notice this when they
check the schematics earlier this is a
pretty big basic area the ship that
would show up on blueprints right you
know is annoying as Hudson is in this
movie I'm gonna knock off a sin for help
bill pass can please him maybe I'm being
sentimental but damn he went full-on
into this role but I'm also going to
Edison back for this sudden alien in the
door where that comes out of nowhere
you mean the aliens sent a whole group
through the ceiling and then this one
asshole through the floor yep Burke is
dead my question is though how did he
expect us to revive any of this when all
the exits were sealed they were waiting
for Bishop to do his while they stayed
safely behind the walls so I don't know
what he was really expected here which
way is it to the landing field from here
I know newts been crawling through these
tunnels for a long time but how did she
keep track of where the landing field
was during her crawling experiences
dental drill screaming as amazing as
these aliens are at finding people
wherever they may be
it's insane they didn't find new tide
away from earlier in the movie before
Ripley did not that an alien really
needs the element of surprise in this
situation but why not just drag Newt
underwater before announcing its
presence every other asshole that's been
attacked by these aliens is super fuckin
debt but Ripley immediately assumes Newt
survived this also Ripley's readout
showed several xenomorphs directly
coming at them but only one kidnap
snooze so I'm guessing the rest of them
just took a smoke break or something
while Ripley prepares for battle
Hicks casually does a speedball to chill
out after a hard day
don't get me wrong this gearing up
sequence is badass especially featuring
a female character for a change but
Ripley had like a minutes long gun
lesson with Hicks earlier right now
she's a weapons expert and these cocoons
are easy to tear apart oh my god Ripley
has a face hugger honour
oh that's just new Ripley goes on a
rampage against the alien eggs who could
blame her these aliens are super evil
and everyone is better off with them
dead but isn't this facility set to
explode in about five minutes why she
wasting time with this when a she needs
to get back on the ship now and be the
reactors explosion will do this job for
her can we have established rules for
when someone gets acid on them after
shooting an alien cuz it only happens
when the plot really needs it too
seriously even the regular aliens can
climb walls and ceilings with no problem
but the Queen has to take a elevator
what a diva
machina ex machina comes in the form of
bishop in the ship he's piloting unless
Newt had time to get to a bath at some
point during the escape she's
suspiciously free of the alien goo that
was all over her ten minutes ago the
alien queen stowed away on the ship
somewhere patiently waited through the
entire trip before attempting an attack
on Ripley and Newton back in college I
watch this movie in pop culture class
yes I got actual credit for studying pop
culture isn't life awesome anyway we
were told to look for any kind of
symbolism in the movie and in this scene
two people in unison yelled Queen takes
bishop and it was annoyingly clever or
cleverly annoying depending on your
point of view I'm really sorry and glad
to share that with you today in this
video since viewers not only is it
doubtful that the Queen had time to get
on the dropship it is impossible that
she would secretly fit where the landing
gear usually goes also this is a fucking
great scare I spend all this time
cutting bishop in half he's posed zero
threats to the aliens this whole movie
and now she's completely given up the
element of surprise get away from her
you bitch thankfully Ripley toiled in
that menial shipping stocking job at the
base so she could probably come food out
of this mech loader believe it or not
Ripley is in yet another airlock
situation with an alien it's really the
only way to dispose of the final bag
damn it I thought in space no one could
hear you scream
[Music]
no Bishop looks like he's just been
through the worst and most dangerous
porn ever filmed
may is mental health month and it's a
subject that means a lot to us here at
cinema sites in fact we're partnering
with Mental Health America to not only
raise awareness of mental health issues
but also raise a little money to we've
got a brand new cinemasins t-shirt in
the shop that all of the profits from
the sale of the shirt will be donated to
our friends at mhm also if you'd like to
learn more about mental health you can
check out cinemasins comm slash mental
health awareness
we've got mental health screening tools
and detailed information about certain
behaviors that could indicate mental
illness mental health conditions are
real common and treatable we can help
reduce the burden of mental illness by
identifying symptoms and warning signs
early so check out these resources
Mental Health Month works because it's
about what others can do for us and what
we can do for ourselves and crawl to
freedom through 500 yards
[Music]
[Applause]
is there air you don't know yo you're
dead already
there's no place I'm eating you think
it's gone
he's only a model telling me I got a bad
feeling about this drop I got a bad
feeling about this